У нас пролунав зараз тривожний сигнал. І я думаю ми всі знаємо, що треба робити.
Такі навчальні евакуації відбуваються в багатьох українських школах кілька разів на рік.
Однак у вчительки історії Олени Геннадіївни такі заходи
перегукуються з подіями з її минулого.
Коли в червні 2014 року діти прийшли до школи, нас почали обстрілювати
бойовики, не українська армія… Розумієте, це була реальність.
Діти були настільки налякані, ми коли зайшли в приміщення,
де ми мали рятуватися, то головна мета їх була доторкнутися до мене.
Розумієте, 9-ий клас? Дорослі дівчата, дорослі хлопці -
наскільки діти були налякані ситуацією.
У 2014 році Олена Геннадіївна вимушена була переїхати до Києва з Горлівки,
де жила і працювала все життя. Тепер будь-які тренування на випадок небезпеки
у її навчальному закладі жінка сприймає всерйоз. І привчає до цього дітей.
Коли відбуваються такі дні, у першу чергу, ми вчимо дітей бути організованими.
Це не щось веселе, що ми йдемо з уроку. Це така реальність,
яка може бути в житті.  Зараз - не дай Боже, щоб його узнав ще хтось.
Достатньо того, що це узнали ми.
Громадську дискусію про безпеку у школах нещодавно розпочав
освітній омбудсмен України Сергій Горбачов. На тлі ризику повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії Горбачов поцікавився у “Фейсбуці”, чи варто школам
оснащувати укриття і проводити позапланові тренування.
Під постом омбудсмена залишили сотні коментарів.
95%, майже 97% із тих, хто відгукнулися на наш допис із питанням "Чи треба?",
вони глибоко переконані, що треба готувати людей. Без паніки,
без зайвого галасу, але постійно, цілеспрямовано робити цю роботу.
Треба провести навчання такі, щоб були не для галочки, а реальні навчання.
Наразі, як свідчать численні коментар під постом та особисті розмови DW
з представниками шкіл, чимало навчальних закладів не проводять
позапланові тренування, а укриття облаштовують у найпростіший спосіб.
На думку Сергія Горбачова, школи не мали б поверхнево ставитися до тренувань.
Окрім того, навчальні заклади повинні розробляти алгоритми дій
на випадок різних інцидентів. Наприклад, придумати й завчити один тривожний сигнал,
коли вчителі мають якнайшвидше вивести дітей зі школи,
а другий - коли забарикадуватися у класі.
Омбудсмен також вважає, що Державна служба з надзвичайних ситуацій
могла би ініціювати універсальний документ для шкіл щодо дій
під час надзвичайних ситуацій.
Що зібрати у валізку на всяк випадок? Як підготуватися? Які сигнали оповіщення можуть бути?
Ну, коротше кажучи, дуже багато читають... Ось є брошура "Дії
у разі військового конфлікту", і не одна до речі. Але для нас важливо,
щоб такі самі рекомендації, інструкції були і для шкіл, для дітей.
Дискусії щодо безпеки учнів посилилися у суспільстві  і через численні випадки
псевдомінувань у школах країни в перший місяць року. Згідно з даними СБУ,
від початку 2022 року по всій країні надійшло понад 300 анонімних повідомлень
про фейкові мінування. Саме тому школа, в якій тепер вчителює Олена Геннадіївна,
вирішила провести серед учнів урок з мінної безпеки.
На вигляд звичайна іграшка, так. Але в ній знаходиться вибухова речовина.
І під час будь-яких маніпуляцій - ми захочемо підняти, ми захочемо штовхнути,
просто пройти поруч - дана річ може вибухнути.
На думку директорки школи, такі заплановані заходи заспокоюють і батьків, і дітей
- адже демонструють, що всі учасники навчального процесу знають, що робити.
Ясна річ, що це бентежить усіх, і батьки занепокоєні тим, що відбувається.
Вони хотіли би бути впевненими в тому, що їхні діти убезпечені в школі,
і школа готова до будь-яких дій у разі будь-якої загрози.
Школярі та їхні батьки теж визнають, що іноді їм буває тривожно.
Однак загалом вони не панікують, зокрема завдяки таким навчанням.
Я насправді не дуже хвилююся, бо це все фейки.
Приколюються або якісь ворожі агенти це роблять. Хай діти розважаються.
Так, ці тренування мені дуже допомагають. Щоб не панікувати, щоб знати, що робити.
Мені більше всього, частіше, розповідають про це в школі.
Батьки якось не так хвилюються, бо розуміють, що в школі про це розповідають.
Важливо таке проводити. Діти, яких, наприклад, сьогодні немає,
а завтра вони прийдуть, чи прийдуть через тиждень - вони не будуть знати, що їм робити.
Особливо діти початкових класів. Вони панікують, можуть забути свої речі в класі.
Тож допоки правоохоронці щоразу перевіряють, наскільки реальна небезпека,
наприклад, після повідомлення про нібито мінування, школярі та вчителі
можуть зробити свій внесок. Подбати про власну безпеку,
сумлінно запам’ятовуючи алгоритм дій та тренуючись на  випадок небезпеки.